just do it this is do it just do it just
go and do it just do it do something
hello believe nation today we're going
to talk about how you can just do it as
usual as you guys watch the video if
somebody says something that really
really resonates with you please leave
it in the comments and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired as
well just do it just pick up a camera
and start shooting something don't wait
to be asked because nobody's going to
ask you and don't wait for the perfect
conditions because they'll never be
perfect it's a little bit like having a
child if you wait until the right time
to have a child you'll die childless and
I think filmmaking is very much the same
thing you just have to take the plunge
and just start shooting something even
if it's bad you can always hide it but
you will have learned something okay the
question is do you the person asking the
question have what it takes to do what
Dan did and you never know but no one
does know initially upfront you have to
try you have to swing at the plate you
have to you know take risk you have to
be willing to sacrifice you have to be
one of the make commitment then just do
it I keep saying that I mean it's it's
simplistic it sounds like I'm you know
I'm not having thought the question Jim
but that's not the point at all the
point is after twenty-one years of
coaching and after almost 45 years of
doing this myself and being high
performance person in six decades I
realized you just got to do it I had
done the Fantastic Four and the x-men
and my publisher said hey they're doing
well do another one so I came up with
spider-man and I said to him I got this
great idea what a quote spider-man and
he's a teenager so I gave him the idea
and he said stand that is the worst idea
I have ever heard he said first of all
people hate spiders you can't call it
hero spider-man secondly he said he
can't be a teenager teenagers are only
sidekicks and finally he can't have
personal problems don't you know what a
superhero is
so he wouldn't let me do it one day we
had a book we were going to kill called
amazing fantasy when you're gonna do the
last issue nobody cares what you put in
it just to get it out of my system
I put spider-man in the book and we sold
it and it was a best-seller so my
publisher called me in a couple weeks
later zit stand you remember that
character spider-man that you and I
liked so much when he do a series of it
and that's how Spidey was born I believe
desire and will to win is everything I
don't know why I'm like I am but my
butt's always burning there's always
something say art dadgummit you're
supposed to go far all right dad gummit
you're supposed to be somebody you're
supposed to make a difference with you
lie
what does the $500,000 your person do
the $50,000 your person doesn't do you
look at outside and study those two
individuals everything seems to be the
same they both are the same sex they
both are the same age they have the same
training the same positions the same
contract the same fringe benefits
they both are successful they work hard
they're good family people make tough
commitments but what's the difference
what does the $500,000 year person do
the $50,000 year person doesn't do he
pays the price and a little bit more he
works Harding a little bit more he's
loyal to the company a little bit more
he believes in a little bit more he
makes Maine a little bit more he saves
money a little bit more if you want to
win in these United States you got to be
tough and you can't quit the last thing
I'll talk to you about today and
building this winning edge is folks if
you want to win in business you've got
to be a leader leadership is everything
you show me anything in these United
States that win I'll show you leader at
work you show me a successful church Boy
Scout Troop club football team business
I'll show you some a run by leader see
see I thought at one time in my life you
had to be smart to win I used to have
these smart people that dress so pretty
and talk so pretty and use these big
words they just intimidated me and I
said arch you can't ever be that good
why don't you just throw in the towel
and go on bank coach
ball for living and I found two things
out about smart people I think it's
almost impossible for a smart person to
win in business in America today because
I find smart people spend their whole
lifetime figuring things out they always
trying to figure out an easier way in a
quicker way and another thing I found
out about smart people as they just
don't get around to doing nothing they
see somebody like art Williams everybody
says well he can't do it and somebody
like that can't do it but he does it see
folks I want you to know almost
everybody in America almost does enough
to win they almost get there they almost
over the hump they almost have it going
they almost in everything they do almost
is a way of life to almost everybody in
America but the winners do it what do
they do they do whatever it takes to get
the job done they do it and do it and do
it and do it and do it until the job
gets done and then they talk about how
great it is to be somebody they're proud
of we need leaders in America who can do
it if you want to become somebody do it
if you want to go in business for
yourself do it if you want to become
financially independent do it I hear too
much talk in these United States
everybody can talk a good game we need
people in America who can do it I go all
over this country with Al weaves and I
have people say art you you count on me
wonderful just do it alright I guarantee
this is my light last stop I'm gonna win
now
SuperDuper just do it alright if I could
just have one good month and get the
ball going I know I could make it big
super just do it
hard if I could just pay off this debt I
could really go great just do it hard if
I could just sell my house do it but
houses he's selling do it anyway
oh I'm not making any money what can I
do you just do it and do what are you do
it and do it and do it alright I get to
win this contest
SuperDuper just do it alright I'm over
the hump now watch my smoke grades just
do it alright I want to make it so bad
I'm tasting what I do you just do it
alright I'm a vice president now can I
quit doing it no my heart I don't know
if I keep on keeping on I'm really
hurting what I do you just do it do what
art you do it and do it and do it
alright all my life I want to be
somebody important well what do it then
alright I'm gonna save money so I don't
have to go through this again gray Hey
just do it alright I don't feel like
I've had enough training what I do you
just do it alright my manager don't give
me no help what I do you just do it all
right you don't understand I was mr.
everything in my former company you
don't mean I I have to start off down at
the bottom and do it do you yep you
really got to do it ah
art was the primary difference between
winners and losers the winner the
winners do it they do it and do it and
do it and do it until the job gets done
and then they talk about how great it is
to finally have achieved something
unique and how glad they are that they
didn't quit like everybody else and how
wonderful it is to finally be somebody
they're proud of and make a difference
with their life if you get if you get
the passion if you got the passion to do
it and you do it and it doesn't like
work out I worked for got three years on
a 16 millimeter film that end up
becoming nothing with guitar picks and
uh and I was very disappointed when I
realized it wasn't any good but it was
my film school alright and I actually
got away really cheap when it was all
over I knew how to make a movie I didn't
want to show anybody that but I had the
experience I had a lot cheaper than I
would have gone if I'd gone to film
school um so do you have any advice for
someone who would like to start doing
creative writing but has no idea where
to start whatsoever um depends are you
the kind of person who arm do you read a
lot I read a lot yes
I write snarky emails but that's bad
I've been told they're very good I mean
when you say creative writing do you
want to write fiction do you want to
write humorous essays do you want to
those in fiction I would think you want
to do stories yes okay so my advice is
start writing stories just like do it um
really it's almost as simple as that
it's start writing so pick a bigger
style pick a theme look at the kind of
you know you are not expected straight
out of the Hat to be a brave and
original voice producing fine and
wonderful fiction it's much more like
you know the first pancake on the
griddle which is gonna be this weird
black messy thing that you will either
give to your dog or to a child try to
convince them yeah it's nice
hey you know it's you will you you're
right you finish things you start the
next thing you write that you finish it
someone there you get reasonably good
arm any of these two people or do you
just yeah I the the point I always found
that I I would always learn more about
what I'd done the moment I saw it in
print or the moment these days probably
the moment you'd see things up on the
web but yeah hum to people um but the
most important thing when you're just
starting out is write the next one
assume that you have you know a million
words inside you that are absolute
rubbish and you need to get them out
before you get to the good ones and if
you get there early that's great that
that's really my biggest advice thank
you read everything you can read outside
your comfort zone and write a lot when
you look at the accomplishments of
accomplished people and you say boy that
must have been really hard you know when
you look at something that looks hard
that was probably easy and conversely
when you look at something that looks
easy that was probably hard and so
you're never going to know which is
which until you actually go and do it so
just go and do it
try learn from it you know you'll fail
at some things that's a learning
experience that you need so that you can
take that on to the next experience and
don't let people who you may respect and
who you believe know what they're
talking about don't let them tell you it
can't be done
because often they will tell you it
can't be done and it's just because they
don't have the courage to try it you've
been in a band for seven years you could
have been a big star as a solo artist
but that explains why you put wings
together because you needed people to
work with on a live stage yeah I like
the idea of abandoned you know because
people said we've got a big super super
group load the Stars and support for
some mad region I wanted to kind of go
back to square one and just do it as we
done it in the Beatles so people said
well Linda can't play keyboards and it
was true yeah I said well I know but you
know and we call a guitar you know John
can play guitar when we started you know
he's playing banjo chords you know and
we knew Linda couldn't play we knew we
didn't know each other and put you
learned and but we had some funny
experiences I mean looking back on it
I'm really glad we did it because it was
the way to do it like I say I could have
just gone into a super group and just
rung up Erika Jimmy Page jump on him or
whatever oh and you know just the mates
and said come on guys we're going to do
it but for some reason I wanted to go
back and it was quite funny we ended up
as you say playing universities and
graduated to town halls and it was funny
because I've been in a stadium by
recently you know and it was it was
funny who knows yeah to hold you nerve
but then you do in life you know you've
got to this is all sorts of occasions
that throw you and you've got to decide
ok I'm going under or I'm going up yeah
and so we just decided to get out and do
it and it was funny
we run New Castle Town Hall once and
we're doing this song wildlife so and
Linda had the intro it's just three
little piano chords don't you don't you
jump don't you and so I go either a song
out called wildlife
one two three one two three nothing I
look round she's going so now the
audience love this I think this is part
of the show hey love it like one two
three one two three more nothing so I
turn round the audience by this time I
think this is great you know that we've
worked this out this is a comedy bit so
I go over to the piano I go and I can't
remember this is hell now suddenly it
comes back to her good thing - yes
well I've wore off there's a lot harder
to get started when I was growing up and
wanting to be a movie director
almost at 12 years old because when I
first picked up a camera in order to get
out where were you living with you I was
in from Scottsdale here in Arizona you
know I got honey I was looking for a way
to get fulfill the requirements to get a
photography merit badge I was in the Boy
Scouts of America and the manager said
he'll make her before no I don't be a
filmmaker at all I would want to be a
Eagle Scout that was my only aspiration
was become want to get the highest rank
I could in this in scouting and so on my
way to being an Eagle Scout I had to get
a certain you know requisite amount of
merit badges and one of them I want to
get was photography and the requirement
was to tell a story was still
photographs and my dad's camera broke he
did not have a still camera like the
brownie Kodak that he had wasn't working
so I but he did an eight-millimeter
Kodak eight millimeter movie camera and
I went to the Scoutmaster and I said can
we change the rules just so I can tell a
story on film because we don't have a
still camera and the Scoutmaster said go
ahead and do it so I got three minutes
worth of film which is by the way all
those cameras used to take these little
three minute rolls of film and I made
this Western on a weekend and I show
that you headed you edit did you camera
cutting a camera cut you know a little
shot at my friends and cowboy outfits
robbing a stagecoach which was sort of
an exhibit out in front of a place
called Pinnacle Peak patio a restaurant
which is still there outside of scotch
did you know - camera can you just I
just figured out you know you do a shot
in this direction of the bad guys with
guns masks on and my citrus played the
damsels in distress and the stagecoach
giving away their costume jewelry well
my mother's jewelry I didn't tell her we
took my bottom jewelry to give away to
12 year olds you know pretending to be
about robbers and I made this little
movie and then showed it to the Boy
Scout Troop that weekend and they all
went crazy for it they screamed and
applauded and I suddenly got bitten by
that bug and I wanted to do this for the
rest of my life it was like became so
clear to me but it was hard then because
to make movies you had to pay for film
and pay for developing of the film so I
had to go to my dad to say dad you know
our and some money but I can't earn all
the money because I I go to school I
can't get a job to earn the money to pay
for all this equipment so my dad helped
me however today it's easier today
everybody seems to have a camcorder
everybody has some high eight digital
camera and it's a lot easier to get your
hands on you buy that editing program
for the computer you can buy it as
software program for the computer and go
out and make a movie in tell a story and
figure out who you are as a storyteller
and and so in a sense it's easier today
for young people to at least prove to
themselves is what they want to do for
the rest of their lives or at least in
the interim of the rest of their lives
and it's also if you get bitten by that
bug you can make a lot little movies and
somehow those films will get seen by
people hopefully that will hire you do a
music video someday or a TV commercial
or a television show or someday a
feature film I think that the best
advice I could give everyone is still
listen to advice but if you are going to
listen to advice then making sure you
actually do something is a good advice
if you just sit around planning
something and not doing it you're not
actually going to get anywhere thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know which the clips
did you enjoy the most what impact is it
going to have on your life or business
what change you're going to make how are
you going to just do it now in your life
or your business leave it down the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you again for watching
I believe in you I hope that you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon